c'est une séquence diffusée le 31
octobre 2010 est sur france 2 dans
l'émission ça commence aujourd'hui qui
refait surface je suis entouré de trois
femmes qui ont choisi d'aimer malgré la
différence d'âge un extrait de
l'émission présentée par faustine
bollaert qui avait pour thème je laime
malgré notre différence d'âge elles ont
dû affronter la compréhension pour ne
pas dire le jugement de leurs proches
mais aussi leurs propres interrogations
par rapport à cet écart parfois très
importantes trop important pour certains
sujets dont certains pourraient se
sentir concerné mais là le témoignage
d'elodie dépasse tout ce que l'on
pourrait imaginer vous avez quel âge à
l'époque j'avais 22 ans
si ce n'est pas forcément l'écart d'âge
de nouveau qui peut choquer c'est
surtout l'âge du garçon âgée de
seulement 13 ans à l'époque tous les
deux vous aviez une vie intime oui je
vais à la suite de ça je suis tombée
enceinte de lui une séquence qui pose la
question sur l'âge légal de consentement
alors enceinte à 22 ans d'un garçon de
13 ans comprenez vous que le témoignage
de ça commence aujourd'hui face au
scandale
alors c'est vrai que ça ressort
aujourd'hui est ce que vous comprenez
que ça parce qu'on a mené au tendon oui
ah bah moi c'est écrit me met
extrêmement malaise déjà c'est bien
parce que ça existe qu'il faut le mettre
en avant dans une émission de
témoignages c'est pas non plus une
émission d'information et puis ensuite
ce qui m'agace c'est que le ton de
l'interview est particulièrement
bienveillants parce que c'est une femme
j'aurais bien voulu voir ça aurait donné
ça a été un honneur il en deux ans
encadrés j'ai mis en france est une
fille de 13 ans tu voudras dexter
pédophiles ça la vérité oui
madame oui alors moi c'est valérie boyer
bonsoir non je suis d'accord avec avec
guillaume en l'occurrence moi ça m'a
fait penser à un livre le livre de
vanessa spring aura sur l'emprise où
elle était elle avait 15 ans et elle
clamait haut et fort à tout le monde
qu'elle était amoureuse de l'homme avec
lequel elle était qui avait 40 en plus
quel est donc le mois ça pose vraiment
cette question du consentement quand on
a 12 13 14 ans même si on clame haut et
fort qu'on est amoureux est-ce qu'on
peut être vraiment amoureux de quelqu'un
de beaucoup plus âgée de 10 ans de plus
20 ans de plus 30 ans de plus donc ça
pose cette question de l'emprise et
voilà est effectivement tu as raison si
on avait inversé qu'on avait mis un
homme avec une jeune femme de 13 ans
sont arrêtés un scandale sur ses décors
et vous évaluerez bd oui delphine
ya plein de d'ados qui font leur
première fois 13 ans voilà il suffit
d'un accident sur la première fois 13
ans pour que la personne enfin
effectivement
il a 13 ans donc qu'est voilà les gens
qui font ça non non ça ne me choque pas
non mais mathieu en fait je suis donc
pas ton avis donc je donne mon avis
ça fait toujours et orale à la haye les
deux les deux samax terminée c'est censé
être une émission les gens viennent sans
jugement se livrer et c'est une émission
il n'y a pas de jugement justement ça
commence aujourd'hui thème mathieu
delphine pardon je suis diminué mais il
ya un fugitif est en france une loi là
il fait que la majorité sexuelle ses 16
ans pour qu'on considère qu'avant on n'a
pas de discernement pour savoir ce
qu'est un amour ou peut-être contrat
quelqu'un qui abuse de toi ça a été
calculé ça a été très bien fait donc non
à 13 ans cette jeune fille n'a pas de
discernement pour savoir si elle est
amoureuse pas amoureux et ressassé par
la garde après celle et toi tu côtoies
renommée s'est confondu
en histoire de sexe une fois et une
relation de quelqu'un qui à 22 ans de
plus tiens 15 avec canon sans pardon 22
et 13 ans
16 ans mais c'était par mois je ne
savais pas du tout un plan cul avant 16
ans j'étais avec quelqu'un j'ai commencé
d'ailleurs à 13 ans et c'est une
relation très sérieuse avec qui j'aurai
c'est pendant neuf ans problème qui
était majeure non on avait le même âge
rue du change tout mais ne change ou
delphine parle de moi un garçon pourquoi
pas précoce fait l'amour avec une jeune
fille elle aussi précoce mais ils ont le
même âge c'est pas la même problématique
là ce qui pose question c'est qu'on a
une gêne à une personne qui est majeure
au dessus de la de la majorité avec
quelqu'un qui est en dessous y compris
de la majorité sexuelle donc c'est là
donc à une vraie
génie pas que cette femme est une
prédatrice puisque lll donc quand on
écoute vraiment dans la longueur elle
dit
je me suis regardé je ne savais pas
défilée vu en fait c'était tout de suite
the way we tout et vous pensez que vous
à regarder la même manière ce premier
jour oui j'espère il me l'a avoué donc
vous avez quel âge à l'époque j'avais 22
ans et lui il en avait il allait revoir
car il avait 13 à 13 ans elle fait 14
ans l'aviez-vous non tous les deux vous
aviez une vie intime oui je vais à la
suite de ça je suis tombée enceinte de
pluie et je suis parti sans lui donner
d'explications c'est ça le plus choquant
alors oui c'est ça c'est ça le plus
choquant parce que évidemment on peut
avoir une différence d'âge après la
mairie d'accord avec mathieu elle est
hors la loi parce qu'à 13 ans il ya
c'est un détournement de mineur et donc
c'est très grave après ses locaux le
côté je suis tombée enceinte où ça veut
dire qu'elle sait pas protégés c'est à
dire qu'à pas de pilule ça veut dire
qu'à pas de préservatif donc on tombe
enceinte comme ça bon ben c'est pas
grave après tout on tombe enceinte
comment va dans un magasin où on va au
fast food et puis après on se tire parce
que bon après tout c'est pas grave on
part donc on fait un enfant comme ça
puis après on a il ya plus de pères
façon d'irresponsabilité aujourd'hui on
fait des enfants comme ça mais ça je
trouve que c'est super grave donc voilà
donc je trouve que c est triste et
choquant vraiment et pas d'accord moi
maintenant à mon âge et moi j'étais
scandalisé quand j'ai eu le sujet agi
mais quoi 13 ans mais des tarés et j'ai
été faire de replay j'étais regarder des
extraits en fait pourquoi j'ai mis non
parce que d'abord je cours je suis
d'accord à guillaume si c'est un mec qui
a fait ça mais qu'hélas il serait foutu
mais landes elle le dit bien a dit qu il
avait 14 ans à 10 14 heures prend 10 13
et dit qu'il était plus grands qui
faisait pas son âge
pensez peut-être qu'il avait 16 ans de
la majoration de sectional study et
après l'otan
suivez moi je suis un gars on
l'attendait à 65 ans non mais
il est il est grand équilibre qui fait
plus que son âge à 13 ans il était grand
baraqué ne faisait plus que son âge a pu
donner 16 ans ou 17 n'aura plus de ça te
pardonne moi je n'ai pas eu envie que
mon garçon de 13 ans qui qui peut être
affectivement ajustements la secte d'un
enfant de 13 ans et paix et le corps
d'un homme de 17 18 ou 20 ans n'a qu il
soit dès qu'une femme book mais là tu
m'en donnes et toi tu parles à taper par
la presse quel jeu quand il faut faire
place de ton fils il est vrai grâce à
shopreflex non je suis sur le discours
de la femme en salle je te rejoins
entièrement alors un préservatif
regardez regardez pas ce que lorsqu'elle
apprend son âge elodie part pour
l'observer j ai l on retrouvera des
années plus tard isaac était d'ailleurs
sur le plateau et pour raconter son
histoire regarde je pense que je pense
que se doutait que je peut-être pas
j'étais j'avais bottes matures à 13 ans
il veut un enfant ça peut être compliqué
quand vous avez vous dû à ce moment là
le protéger aussi de sa wii aussi voici
way we aussi
avec par rapport au regard des gens
aussi à ce qu'ils allaient dire
forcément aussi et donc du coup c'était
je me suis dit ah très enfin il est fort
il supporterait peut-être pas tout ce
qu'on aurait pu lui dire à l'époque si
on aurait levé notre fille tous les deux
pas sûr alors oui là mais que font les
parents dans ces cas-là il ya qu'elles
sont des enfants dont hessel parents à
surveiller ce qui se passait a indiqué
la jeune fille comment se protéger a
expliqué ce que c'est que l'amour
physique et et c est pareil pour le
garçon et berna festival des charentes a
pas d'enfants tués
mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faudra suivre ton enfance il est parti
faire un plan avec leur nom l'indiqué
mais c'est quand même mais c'est vous
qui
l'avez les crevasses oui moi ce qui me
choque c'est que france télévisions avec
faustin qui est un grand sourire comme
ça et les reçoit et patati tombe
amoureux à 13 ans il faisait quoi vous
coucher ensemble et pénétrations machin
on est sur le service public on entraîne
parler quand même deux choses qui sont
illégales et c'est un témoignage comme
si c'était un témoignage de
n'importe quoi il est pas 23
rencontres en compte délivrer un
témoignage de m
alors
débuté lorsque alan on reçoit pas
d'argent
mais c'est pareil 19h ce encore et
encore plus aux conditions d'accueil
à vivre les troncs et monté juste une
chose juste une possible là où je
rejoins malgré tout mathieu évidemment
sans rejoignez le aux toilettes
évidemment c'est une émission
testimoniale est évidemment ils sont
dans la bienveillance et donc ya pas de
jugement et ça c'est très bien tant
mieux mais en revanche il faut quand
même qui est sur le plateau une parole
qui disent à un moment même si on
l'évoquent et la personne répond en
disant ces hors la loi que c'est hors la
loi si vous avez quelque chose et après
elle répond sans l'agresser ensemble
sans le dire que vous avez fait un truc
qui m'ont écouté mais juste le signaler
pour expliquer aux tests étaient mortes
et regarde moi tous sont hors d'âge non
j'ai géré la banco pour soi le dealer
avec bien sûr on les remet pas en
bandeau vendent de la drogue est
interdite par la loi évident
il a raison mais
il ya un roswell d une question très bon
vin le dealer cyril arrêtez pas lui dire
vous savez oui c'est illégal c'est pas
bien et c'est tard il ya eu deux trois
blagues d'accord mais c'était pas une
émission bienveillante on n'existait pas
une interview bienveillant là où est la
limite cercle demain y'a un mec de 30
ans qui va venir qui va dire alors dame
en fait j'ai une aventure et une fille
de 10 ans à oui c'est formidable banon
marvel avait même la limite de la
rupture avec moi oui mais la grille
d'accords ma douce traité de conneries
du témoin là c'est que la fille ne
savait pas qu'il avait 13 ans et en
syrie c'est quand celle-ci longtemps et
non elle savait pas des gains a su dès
qu'elle a su s est barré mais non il va
c'est un enfant avec un enfant dans
laquelle assure que ces barrettes à
lombez mais ça reste quand même un
scandale mais pour moi je ne savais pas
c'est le dinar mais si les gens se
sentent jugé alors ils vont plus dans
cette émission le but c'est d'avoir
vraiment des parcours de vie incroyable
qui peuvent un peu touché certaines
personnes et si c'est une émission lis
ça ne vaut plus que d'être regardé cette
émission elle est plaisante parce qu'il
ya des choses
dures il ya des choses des décors au
groland et donc ça me regarde
je veux dire ce que dit la loi depuis
janvier dernier le sénat a adopté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi
visant à fixer à présent la seuil en
deçà duquel un mineur ne peut consentir
un rapport sexuel avec un adulte un
majeur qui aurait un rapport avec une
personne de moins de 13 ans serait donc
aussi mac m'ont accusé de viol dans le
cas présent illzach avait déjà 13 ans
lorsqu'un majeur à une relation sexuelle
avec un mineur de moins de 15 ans même
si ce dernier était consentant le majeur
pour être poursuivi pour le délit
d'atteinte sexuelle sur mineur ce qui
est puni de 7 ans de prison et 200 mille
euros d'amendé ça c'est pas de lui dire
ça oui juste faustine à la une fiche
comme vous et elle le dit en préambule
et après l'acte et moi et moi je vais
plus loin cette loi les pourris en 13
ans présente tu as le droit à partir de
14 ans à droite non mais quelle connerie
c'est plus normand ça devrait être 16
ans 17 ans cette présence est trop tôt
par exemple tu peux pas dire qu'à un
garçon ou une fille à 13 ans elle c'est
vraiment tout ce qu'elle a dans sa tête
elle peut pas semble s'embarquer dans
une sexualité avec un mec de 18 19 ans
c'était j'ai rien contre toi delphine
mais si désolée c'est pas tout est
possible c'est pas une émission on
arrive on monte des trucs pourquoi pas
je tape mon cher machin étonnant cette
mission à savoir
si les témoignages pression c'était les
spectateurs s'il vous plaît les chéris
merci oui 80% il nous arrive pour cent
oui il ya des gens foncent ont souri
pour ça que j'aime et oui moi